he has changed a lot and I bet you may
not remember the time Luffy absorbed the
power of 100 Shadows you probably also
forgot the time he went undercover
inside a Marine base and you definitely
didn't know about the time that Luffy
became a literal Thunder giant all the
way back in 2009. well in this video
we're going to explain every single step
in the evolution of Luffy on his path to
becoming pirate king and in the
impossible case that you actually do
remember every single version of Luffy
in this video you can truly call
yourself a one-piece Master at the end
starting with Luffy as a kid when Luffy
first meet Shanks he's seven years old
determined to be a pirate Luffy stabs
himself in the face just to show Shanks
that he's brave enough to join the crew
shank says that he's still too young and
while Luffy is disappointed he has
earned the respect of shanks's crew
which is great until Luffy eats his
legendary devil fruits because now an
angry Shanks tells Luffy that his entire
body has become Rubber and he can no
longer swim pretty silly right well just
wait until you see how this one bite of
fruit changes Luffy's life forever soon
after Luffy is safe from Bandits he gets
his iconic straw hat from Shanks and
promises that he will become a great
pirate and that promise Begins by
training with his adopted Brothers Ace
and Sabo these three boys grow Stronger
by fighting wild beasts of the Jungle
and Luffy learns to control his new
rubber body but beyond just growing
stronger ASAP and Luffy also form a bond
of true Brotherhood that teaches Luffy
to never give up on his friends and when
already skipping forward to 17 year old
Luffy that starts his journey he's
strong confident and dreams of becoming
King of the Pirates and he sets out on a
small boat ready to gather a really
strong crew Luffy's next step is to
become a real pirate Captain chapter 42
Luffy is giving a proper ship after
saving usop's Hometown and together with
his three new crewmates they designed
their very first flag now in case you
don't know flags and other symbols are
incredibly important in the one piece
story stick around and you'll see why
now this smiling symbol shows the world
that the straw had Pirates have arrived
bringing hope to many across the world
Luffy is truly a pirate captain now but
he still has much to learn including
that pirates are not the only force in
the world after defeating the Fishman
are long and freeing nami's Village
Luffy becomes a wanted man with a bounty
of 30 million berries the world
government has taken notice of Luffy's
victories in the East blue and they
decide that he is now enough of a threat
that they would pay for someone to
capture or even kill Luffy which of
course goes to show that in addition to
making friends Luffy is also gaining
enemies and the world government almost
gets their wish right away in loketown
the scene of Goldie raja's execution
Luffy is captured and almost executed by
the pirate buggy the clown but despite
knives hanging literally over his neck
Luffy just laughs in the face of death
he shouts to the onlooking crowd that he
is more than happy to die in pursuit of
his own dreams and those in the crowd
who knew Roger are struck by the
similarities between this rubber boy and
the former Pirates King and just like
Roger it seems that Luffy is protected
by more than just his strong will and
desire because suddenly a freak storm
sets him free and now he and his crew
finally can enter the grand Line This Is
Where Pirates can truly make a name for
themselves and those wishing to become
pirate king are truly tested here but
even still Luffy still has much much
more to learn if he wants to protect his
friends and pursue his dreams and
speaking of dreams do you remember when
we mentioned that flags are important
while in drum Island Luffy takes a full
Cannon blast to protect the flag of Dr
hero look this quack doctor is the man
who raised Chopper and gave us one of
the most quotes in one piece and by
protecting the flag Luffy shows his
friends that no one will get in the way
of their dream and in the end it is this
bravery that convinces Chopper to pursue
his own dream and finally join the crew
however after this Luffy's fate is very
quickly tested when he gets impaled on
the hook of the warlord crocodile while
fighting against the sand devil fruit
user Luffy is unable to land even a
single punch the warlord marks Luffy's
dreams and throws him into the sand to
die and while Luffy somehow manages to
survive this is his first major defeat
by a villain and it shows us all that he
has a long way to go before he is King
Of Anything luckily though learning is
one of Luffy's biggest strengths
especially when it comes to fighting in
the next battle Luffy uses this
ridiculously looking form where he has
drunk an absurd amount of water because
you see Luffy has learned that because
each logia devil fruit turns the use
into an element each of them also has a
unique natural weakness and so since
crocodile is made out of sand getting
him wet makes the sand of his body stick
together allowing Luffy to actually land
his attacks and even though Luffy loses
this battle again he eventually manages
to defeat crocodile just a short while
later and saves the kingdom of alabaster
and now having defeated his first
warlord of the sea Luffy earns his
second Bounty with an increase from 30
million to 100 million berries this
shows that the world government views
Luffy as a growing threat and once taken
care of however as you probably know
bounties are not the only measure of
strength here on the island of Jaya
Luffy Nami and zaro are mocked by the
pirate Bellamy who spills food and
drinks over the straw Hat's head Bellamy
states that Pirate's dreams are foolish
and that Luffy and his crew should be
afraid of him however this moment really
shows us just how much Luffy has matured
since we saw him as a child in chapter
one instead of fighting back against
Pirates Who are clearly beneath him
Luffy simply walks away a striking
similarity to Shanks all the way back at
the start of the series but this is the
last time that Bellamy takes advantage
of Luffy or his friends because the next
time that Luffy sees Bellamy the pirate
has beaten up these guys and Luffy is
out for Revenge despite Bellamy's
bringing around with the power of His
devil fruit Luffy delivers just one of
the most iconic punches in the series
taking out Bellamy with a single hit and
this shows Bellamy not to underestimate
the power of Dreams or make judgments
based on only someone's bounty and also
on Jaya Luffy's Rising bounty has drawn
the attention of Blackbeard now these
two Pirates will be connected throughout
the entire story the author of One Piece
introduces Blackbeard as Luffy's
physical and philosophical opposites
Luffy small Blackbird is big if Luffy is
very honest Blackbeard is very deceptive
and Luffy hates this cherry pie why
Blackbeard absolutely loves it they are
the light and the Dark of the one piece
World however they also both believe in
the power of dreams and a little bit
later the straw hats actually escaped
from Blackbeard's attempt to capture
them and while Luffy thinks that
blackbeat is strange he cannot imagine
yet the pain that this man will cause
him and the hate that he will later feel
towards this man now the only thing we
love more about Luffy than his growing
strength and fame are the countless
times he makes his friends or us viewers
Laugh In fact there are so many
instances of Luffy acting comically
stupid that it would probably deserve a
whole video of its own but I still want
to focus on a few examples here just on
Skype here for instance Luffy makes fun
of both Zoro and Sanji as they head
towards a deadly trial he hilariously
turns his brain off in order to find NL
and he throws a massive party with the
wild animals of the forest and by the
way it is this exact scene right here
that Oda has stated is one of his top
three favorite scenes that he has ever
drawn at any time anywhere in the world
this man can make friends partying
laughing and having fun he gives hope to
those in need and freedom to those who
are slaves and it turns out that this is
our first major piece of foreshadowing
for Luffy's true Powers at the end of
this video and speaking of Liberation
skypia is also the very first time that
Luffy fights a so-called god of the one
piece World in this Arc the lightning
fruit user NL has Enslaved the citizens
of skypier he's about to destroy the
land and people before traveling to the
moon but with a ball of gold stuck to
his arm Luffy defeats Eno ringing the
legendary Bell of shandora the ringing
of the Bell travels far down to the
actual sea level giving Luffy his
friends hope and reminding them to never
give up on their dreams either and one
dream that we only got to see in the
anime is Luffy's time as a marine
because in the G8 Filler episodes Luffy
and the crew are stuck in a marine
facility however even disguised as a
marine Luffy cannot resist stealing food
right of the vice apparel's plates and
so this is really the closest that he
gets to fulfilling his grandfather's
dream of Luffy becoming a Marine and by
the way if you're curious what Luffy's
life would have looked like if he
actually had chosen to become a Marine
instead of a pirate I actually made a
whole video about that as well but one
other thing I bet you never expected to
see in one piece is afrolufi I mean come
on who wouldn't want this marvelous head
of hair in their lives I mean we can
definitely all offer our things to God
usop for giving Luffy this incredible
makeover however while the two of them
are still joking around here these two
best friends actually face a major
conflict in water 7 just a short while
later and it is here that we see Luffy's
first major test as a captain with their
ship unable to sail any further Luffy
decides to buy a new one to be able to
continue their journey and usop is
outraged he doesn't want to abandon the
ship for two reasons number one they had
received it as a thank you gift for
saving usab's Village but number two
usop has been the one to repair the ship
throughout their adventures and now up
until this point usop has been feeling
more and more useless compared to
everyone else in the crew and repairing
the ship was his justification for being
part of Luffy's crew and so when Luffy
makes this choice to abandon the ship
usop fears that he will be left behind
as well and rejects his decision by
challenging Luffy to a duel now as you
can imagine this does not go well for
Uso through bitter tears the crew has to
watch Luffy assert himself as Captain
and usop is of course defeated and he
then has to leave the crew and while
this is really hard to watch it also
marks a really important development
point for Luffy as well as Zoro mentions
if the crew can't believe in their
Captain's decisions the crew will fall
apart and so in this this case Luffy
shows us that he's growing as a leader
and even though it is difficult to watch
his best friend suffer he can make tough
decisions for the well-being of the crew
overall however at the same time he's of
course still our lovable idiot Luffy and
he somehow manages to get stuck between
these two buildings like just a few
chapters later and it is here that Luffy
faces his biggest challenge yet with
Robin kidnapped and the crew unable to
defeat those secret government agents
Luffy comes up with a new technique gear
second and with this power up Luffy uses
his rubber body to pump oxygen through
his muscles faster than humanly possible
otherwise as a result this gives him a
huge boost in both speed and power
allowing him to finally defeat one of
the secret agents however as we learned
this power is not without any risk
because this technique will likely
shorten Luffy's lifespan but as Luffy
has learned from Ace and Sabo nothing
else really matters when you need to
protect those you care for and
immediately after the crew stares across
the gap between themselves and the world
government agents Robin is still
captured and tells the crew to leave her
behind but Luffy sees the burden the
world government has put upon Robin and
he orders Usopp to shoot down the
government's flag basically a
declaration of war and seeing the flag
burn it tells Robin that this crew will
do anything or will fight anyone to
protect her and the other friends Luffy
begs Robin to tell him what she really
wants and in response she shouts I want
to live now out of all of Luffy's steps
in his Evolution so far this is probably
the most significant because there is no
going back from challenging the world
government itself and now the rulers of
the world have their eyes on Luffy
however just like with any other
challenge Luffy of course Rises to face
it or in this case he literally grows
because when fighting the government's
most dangerous secret agent Lucy Luffy
reveals another new technique gear third
to achieve this form Luffy blows air
straight into his rap rubber bones
making any part of his body supersize
leading to this this this and this uh
remember when we said that Luffy's
power-ups have downsides well after
Luffy first uses gear third it
temporarily turns him into this chibi
Luffy however eventually Luffy will grow
strong enough to not have this side
effect any longer but for a time at
least it is quite hilarious now after
rescuing Robin and escaping from the
world government it is time for Luffy's
third Bounty 300 million berries three
times his last bouncy truly Luffy has
arrived and has proven himself as a
force to be taken seriously in the grand
line and Luffy's grown so much he
doesn't even need to fight zombies he
just pushes them right back into the
grounds now that was a lot of story
progression for Luffy so next let's take
a quick look at some of the most unique
forms that Luffy has taken in the story
as well as the incredible loyalty and
spirit of his crew first we have or is
Luffy when Luffy's Shadow is stolen by
warlord gekkomoria it is placed into the
frozen body of the Demonic giant horse
now based on moria's devil fruit Powers
the revived auras should be under his
control but the Luffy's strong will
sends orce on a rampage search for meat
and even like looking for his straw hats
classic Luffy but eventually ORS must
follow moria's orders and the straw hat
crew is unable to stop the giant demon
that is until we get this by absorbing
the power of 100 Shadows Luffy
transforms into this dark super form
with the power to easily stop orsa's
massive punch and while this form only
lasts for a few moments Luffy's ability
to command the shadows of so many
individuals demonstrates the strength of
his spirits however what's even more
impressive is the sheer damage that
Luffy takes in order to protect his
friends every time and in one of the
most creative visuals of damage I have
ever seen in any series Luffy literally
becomes pain how does that work well
after defeating moriab the warlord Kuma
arrived lives and wipes out the
exhausted Straw Hat crew Kuma's purpose
is to eliminate Luffy for the world
government but both Zorro and Sanji
demand to take Luffy's place kume is so
impressed by the loyalty to the captain
that instead of killing Luffy Kuma uses
his paw fruit powers to repel all of
Luffy's pain that he has taken so far
and he then gives it to Zorro resulting
in one of the most iconic scenes in one
piece nothing happens well except that
Zorro almost dies I guess however this
sacrifice shows just how much the crew
cares for their captain and Kumar
departs full of respect for the straw
hat crew which is a huge contrast to the
respect this space suit wearing World
Noble deserves because the celestial
dragons are the rulers of the one piece
world and self-proclaimed Gods when he
decides to purchase Luffy's friends as a
slave Luffy punches him so hard it sends
shock waves around the world as a result
Marines quickly arrived to rescue the
world Noble and Luffy welcomes the
challenge however what he he doesn't
know is just how unprepared he is for
what is about to happen with the Marines
Admiral kizaru and Cyborg passifista
sent to capture them the straw hats
struggled to stay alive all of them are
still very much wounded from their fight
with morya and are soundly defeated they
only managed to survive because of Kuma
who instead of Killing Them scatters all
of the straw hats around the world and
now alone wounded and full of doubt
about himself Luffy is maybe at his
lowest point or so he thinks now one
step in Luffy's Evolution you may not be
familiar with is tor Luffy that's right
the God of Thunder himself no not not
that one this one in the movie Strong
World Luffy battles Rogers former rival
Shiki fighting under a storm cloud Luffy
launches his foot Into the Storm and
brings down an electric strike on
shiki's head defeating the former rocks
Pirates alongside Luffy's resistance to
lightning another reoccurring plot point
is Luffy's ability to survive poison and
we do see this this one emphasized in
the underwater government prison imple
down where Luffy is attempting to rescue
his captured brother Ace when Luffy
fights against the warden of the jail he
is covered with so much poison a normal
man would have died instantly however
Luffy survives due to his new friends
and his tremendous will to live and now
we've already discussed that Luffy can
be quite dumb sometimes but we've
already seen that his battle
intelligence is next level during a
prison escape Luffy protects his fellow
escapees by wearing wax armor to keep
back the poisonous Warden and this
protection gives them enough time to
escape imple down which was previously
said to be impossible another insult to
the world's government however the
government and the Marines would both
quickly get their revenge on Luffy you
see Luffy rushes to save his brother who
is said to be publicly executed in
Marine Fort the main base of the Marines
and while Luffy is outmatched by the
upper class fighters of the Marines his
determination to save his brother earns
him the respect of many strong Pirates
and that includes the emperor of the sea
Whitebeard who is also trying to rescue
his crewmate Ace however even their
combined attack doesn't stop the Marines
from beginning the execution and it is
now that Luffy fully announces himself
as a candidate to be pirate king because
as the blades come down on Ace's neck
Luffy unleashes his most dominant power
yet conquerors hockey the will of the
Supreme King this burst of willpower
knocks out wheat individuals and gives
Luffy time to rescue his brother and as
the stun Marines and pirates look on the
Marine Admiral Aquino decides that Luffy
is just as much a threat as Ace and vows
to kill both of them and yet Luffy
succeeds in freeing Ace and the brothers
as gay almost with Luffy powerless to
stop a kainu a sacrifices himself so
that Luffy can live Ace dies and Luffy's
will crumbles he is unable to process
the loss of his beloved brother it is a
painful reminder that for all the
priests that Luffy has made he is still
far away from being able to protect his
friends from the strongest fighters in
the seas and the grief almost breaks
Luffy and only thinking about the love
of his crew helps him recover in the end
he is their captain and he's the one
who's responsible for protecting them so
Luffy must continue to get stronger as a
result Luffy decides that they all need
to train and the straw hats disappear
from the world of pirates for two years
during this time Luffy trains with
Rayleigh learning the basics of haki
that will allow him to fight the
monsters that await in the next part of
the grand Line This is an opportunity to
learn from a true Master but Luffy far
surpassesraeli's expectations because it
takes Luffy only 18 months to learn the
basics of haki and then Rayleigh leaves
so Luffy can further develop on his own
two years later the world has truly
changed including our favorite captain
in fact he looks like this no wait this
no okay okay this all right seriously
though Luffy returns to Saba ODI where
his crew is waiting for him he's
stronger full of confidence and ready to
continue his journey however the Marines
are also waiting and faced with the same
enemies from two years ago Luffy shows
exactly why he has earned his new 400
million Berry bouncy by easily defeating
the cyborg classifistas that nearly
killed his entire crew two years ago it
is a giant leap forward and speaking of
giants Luffy becomes one in his anime
fight with former Marine chuzo well this
time he needed size shifting Lily's
assistance to become a giant it won't be
the last time that we see a giant
strawhead Captain before the end of this
video Luffy continues to show off his
new powers in Fishman Islands surrounded
by a 100 000 enemy Fishman Luffy knocks
out 50 000 of them with a single burst
of conquerors hockey he's one of only a
few characters in the entire series who
is able to actually use that ability and
another new power is the special move
Red Hawk when fighting the Fishman
villain hodie Jones Luffy ignites his
arm finishing the fight with a fiery
punch which he created in memory of his
Fallen brother fire Fist Ace most
importantly it's a sign that he has
finally made peace with his brother's
death and while it doesn't make any
sense why a rubber person should be able
to conjure up fire powers it all makes
sense when Luffy's true abilities are
finally revealed hundreds of chapters
later and speaking of power-ups Luffy's
ultimate transformation is of course
this Centaur Luffy no other explanation
needed and now that Luffy has announced
himself back on the stage he enters the
Realms of pirate politics for the very
first time on Punk Hazard Luffy and the
warlord Trafalgar law form an alliance
to take down emperor of the sea kaido
the strongest creature alive and this
marks another super important step for
Luffy even though Robin warns that
pirate alliances end in betrayal usually
he chooses to trust law as they both
seek to rise to the top of the one piece
World however realistically at their
current power levels neither would have
even the slightest chance against kaido
yet however the alliance shows one of
Luffy's greatest strengths as a captain
he knows that he can't achieve his dream
all on his own if it weren't for his
friends he would get lost starve or just
die of some random poison but instead of
being prideful he offers and accepts
help for everyone's benefits that's
something I think we should all be
learning from Luffy something we
shouldn't learn from Luffy on the other
hand is disguises I mean here he gains
quite the following fighting in the
dressrosa Coliseum dressed as the old
man Lucy it is also in dressrosa that we
get our next step in Luffy's gears with
doflamingo turning the world into
Strings around the straw hats A
desperate Luffy unveils gear fourth this
bouncing ball of rubber and hockey is
the result of Luffy's training for two
entire years and while this form grants
Luffy's Superior speed and power the
initial downside is that he is quickly
losing his energy when he runs out gear
forward deflates and Luffy is unable to
use haki for 10 minutes and so when
doflamingo survives Luffy's first round
of gear 4 Luffy must rely on his friends
to delay the Puppet Master for 10
minutes which they do barely but it is
enough for Luffy to return and punch
still Flamingo straight through the
grounds this is another warlord defeated
by Luffy so now the path to becoming an
emperor of the sea begins and so it is
fitting that Luffy along with earning a
new Bounty of 500 million berries also
gains a larger following at the end of
resrosa because many of the fighters who
took down the doflamingo family pledged
their allegiance to Luffy as a result
this forms the straw hat Grand Fleet a
strong group of pirate captains who will
come to Luffy's Aid whenever they're
called upon and the party doesn't just
stop there on this giant walking
elephant Luffy makes an alliance with
the animal mink tribe of Zoe and the
samurai of wano to take down kaido in
addition they learned that they must
collect the road pornographs in order to
find love Tale the island where the
one-piece treasure can be found now this
is of course a huge moment for Luffy
remember he only started with a small
boat and a dream and now he has a badass
crew tons of allies and he has a clear
picture of how to find the onesies
treasure truly he has come a long way
but there is still much much further to
go as you know now when training with
Rayleigh during the time skip Luffy was
told that hockey blooms mostly during
battle and we can see this when Luffy
goes to the territory of big mom another
emperor of the sea when fighting one of
big mom's commanders Luffy uses Tank Man
a buffed up Zumo version of gear fourth
this form allows him to defeat the
commander and start his March towards
rescuing Sanji from big mom and to do
this Luffy makes another agreement with
another pirate Capone gang beige in this
meeting the two captains plot a way to
take down big mom and we get the most
dapped up version of Luffy to date
pretty clean in my opinion I think and
while we don't get a full-blown fight
between big mom and Luffy quite yet
Luffy fights 4 hours with big mom's
strongest son Charlotte katakuri and it
is during this fight that Luffy learns
his first form of advanced hockey future
sight when fully focusing both Luffy and
katakuri can see moments into the future
and as their fight drags on Luffy also
unveils a new form snake man this forum
emphasizes speed along with future sight
it is a frightening combination for
opponents and another step forward for
Luffy after defeating katakuri Luffy and
the crew as gay big mom's territory
intact and with a copy of big mom's Road
Pony glyph this incredible feat has only
previously been accomplished by former
pirate king Roger and this also marks
the moment where many people in the
world start seeing Luffy as an emperor
of the sea he gets a massive Bounty
increase to 1.5 billion berries and for
the first time ever he has survived a
conflict with an empress crew however
according to thanks Luffy still isn't
ready to fulfill their promise of
becoming a great pirate quite the
demanding Mentor I would say Luffy
finally reaches those Heights in wano
though land of the Samurai filled with
the spirit of Bushido Luffy grabs his
own sword but clearly doesn't know how
to use one and Zorro is horrified to see
Luffy punching with a sword someone
please take Luffy's sword away before he
hurts himself and it isn't one or two
that we get our first full out fight
with an emperor of the sea after Luffy
believes that kaido killed his crew
Luffy attacks the Azure Dragon reigning
punches on the drunken Emperor but he
doesn't even leave so much as a scratch
here when kaido starts fighting
seriously Luffy is taken out in a single
hit leading to his imprisonment and
training Arc for prisoner Luffy and just
like Luffy learned Advanced observation
hockey fighting karakuri in the wano
prison Luffy learns about Advanced
Armament haki also known as Dior this
technique allows Luffy to extend his
haki coding into another object to
destroying it from the inside and so
with weeks and months of practice he
Masters Rio and believes that he has now
what it takes to fight Toe to Toe with
kaido which leads us to the raid on
kaido's Castle where on top of the skull
Dome Luffy confronts the newly Allied
kaido and big mom and here we can see
our fully fledged Captain squaring off
with confidence against the strongest
fighters in the one piece world he is
now truly fighting the gods of one piece
and Luffy starts the battle walking
calmly between them to help his Fallen
friends in maybe the best moment of the
entire show wow like that that serious
balls you have there Luffy but it is
also a really important moment in
Luffy's Journey because these two
Emperors Big Mama kaido have ruled the
Seas for decades they would kill Luffy's
friends in an instant but no longer does
Luffy need to run away to protect his
friends he can actually fight them beat
them and move past them to achieve his
own dreams that they never could in a
flash of violent flames Luffy unleashes
the special technique Red Rock a giant
version of The Red Hawk flame that
symbolizes his brother Luffy smashes
kaido into the ground making the emperor
bleed for the very first time against
Luffy however the rest of the battle
does not go as easily kaido is faster
stronger and has way more experience
than Luffy and Luffy cyrio is not enough
to seriously damage kaido the striat
captain loses again and is cast into the
sea to die but the battle was not a
waste quite yet by fighting kaido Luffy
learns another form of hockey Advanced
conquerors hockey similar to the old
this allows Luffy to channel his
unmatched conquerors ability into his
fists At His Feet Luffy climbs back up
to the top of the skull Dome and
confronts kaido once more and this is
where things get a little bit silly even
with all of Luffy's progress all of his
gears and advanced hockey kaido is still
One Step Above him that is until gear 5
or as we learn the true form of Luffy's
devil fruits the sun God's Nika and this
let me tell you was a Twist that no one
saw coming in this form Luffy turns
completely white and cannot stop
laughing he becomes a true
representation of Freedom allowing Luffy
to fully unleash the most incredible
power in the world his imagination
nicknamed the tune Forest by one piece
fans Luffy turns the fight into a
cartoon he catches and throws lightning
punches straight through the emperor and
even turns Dragon kaido into a jump rope
this fight has become true Insanity The
Warrior of Liberation has awoken however
as with all of Luffy's gears there is a
downside to this as well we can see
during the fight that Luffy's lifespan
is dwindling he repeatedly turns into
this wrinkly old man for him and seems
exhausted by his wild transformation
however even the loss of lifespan
doesn't stop our captain in one last
attack Luffy Rises into the clouds kaido
hovers below him as a flaming
destructor's force of Nature and the
situation really seems hopeless but as
with many of Luffy's fights the answer
is simply to punch harder and that's
what Luffy does he comes out of the
clouds with an enormous fist as big as
an island and he smashes kaido all the
way through wano into the volcanic lava
below the island and with big mom
defeated by other members of The
Alliance the straw hats are victorious
and Days Later Luffy is officially
crowned an emperor of the sea with a new
crazy Bounty of 3 billion berries to
back it up and who knows what crazy new
forms we will see Luffy take before he
finally finds the one piece however
there is a really good chance that
Luffy's final bouncy at the end of the
story will not only surpass that of the
former pirate king but even exceed the
crazy amount of 10 billion berries if
you want to find out more make sure to
watch that video right here thanks for
watching